Joe Biden is in and according to morning
consult he opens with an eight-point
lead not just over Bernie Sanders not
just over the Democrats but over
president Trump himself we will analyze
how that shameless liar Joe Biden stands
in 2020 then the mailbag I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
huge poll numbers for Joe Biden nobody I
think expected this
on his first day we expected it to be a
big day but according to morning consult
and Politico there was a poll just over
the last week of a little under 2,000
registered voters he is now leading
President Trump by 8 points
this is a significant edge over Trump
among key demographics 17 points over
women 17 points over Trump with women
voters 22 points with Millennials 10
points with independents we will get
into how he stands and we'll get into
his shameless lying despicable
announcement video but first admit it
you think cyber crime is something that
happens to other people not you nobody
wants your data right those hackers they
can't get your passwords in your credit
card details you don't need to spend a
very small amount of money to protect
your most important data right right no
you're wrong stealing data from
unsuspecting people on public Wi-Fi is
one of the simplest and cheapest ways
for hackers to make money when you leave
your internet connection unencrypted you
might as well be writing your passwords
and credit card numbers on a huge
billboard for the rest of the world to
see that's why I decided to take action
to protect myself from cyber criminals
I use Express VPN expressvpn secures and
anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP address expressvpn is easy to
use apps that runs seamlessly in the
background of your computer phone and
tablet it's so easy I know you think you
don't need it I know you think oh it's
just some little thing protecting it is
the difference between all of your data
being exposed and having your data
secure you can safely surf on public
Wi-Fi you won't be snooped on for have
or have your personal data stolen for
less than 7 bucks a month you can get
the same expressvpn protection that i
have rated number one VPN service by
TechRadar comes with a 30-day money-back
guarantee protect your online activity
today find out how you get three months
free at expressvpn comm slash michael mi
CH AE l expr ESS v PM dot-com / michael
mi CH AE l for three months free with a
one-year package expressvpn comm /
michael to learn more
what a great day for Joe Biden what a
fabulous open a lot of people who have
been Biden skeptics say that Joe Biden's
best day is gonna be his first day maybe
that's true if that's the case then he's
got a long way to fall before he's
having a bad day this is really good
among Democrats right now Joe Biden has
about 30 percent the number-two
candidate in the race is Bernie Sanders
with 24 percent but that six point lead
is even higher in the early states Iowa
New Hampshire South Carolina Nevada he's
got a lead of about 34 to 26 it's got
more like an eight-point lead there also
important for Joe Biden
you've got 21 22 candidates in the race
right now Joe Biden is the number one
choice for 30% of registered Democrats
but he's the number two choice for
basically everybody for supporters of
Bernie Sanders Kamala Harris Pete Buddha
judge and others Bernie Sanders Oh Biden
rather is the number to pick so if it
comes down to it and people have to pick
and some of their number-one candidates
fall out Joe Biden right now is poised
to pick up all of those votes the the
coalition right now is older it's more
racially diverse and it's more likely to
identify as moderate you might be
surprised by that I think a lot of
people on the Left want to pretend that
Bernie Sanders has the racially diverse
coalition that Bernie Sanders is
bringing in all these more radical
people who are less moderate less
racists less old white guys than Joe
Biden that's not true
Joe Biden has the more racially diverse
coalition the only downside for Joe
Biden right now is that his net
favorability has taken a five-point hit
since January so in January was the
first time stories came out that he
might run his net favorability is down
now 40% of Democrat likely voters have a
positive view of him that's about the
same as Bernie Sanders and only 14% have
a negative view of him so the numbers
are really strong however you got to
remember Hillary Clinton had really good
approval numbers too before she got in
the race Hillary Clinton was the
inevitable candidate inevitable nominee
inevitable future president before
she got into the race and then those
approval ratings took a massive hit once
she got in so what's gonna be more
telling is how those numbers look a week
from now or two weeks from now so how
did Joe Biden open up his campaign he
aired about a three and a half minute or
so campaign announcement this is the
very beginning of the announcement this
is the very first tone that he wants to
set for his campaign Charlottesville
Virginia is home to the author of one of
the great documents in human history
we know it by heart we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal endowed by their creator
with certain inalienable rights we've
heard us so often it's almost a cliche
but it's who we are we haven't always
lived up to these ideals Jefferson
himself didn't but we have never before
walked away from them
Charlotte Sowell is also home to a
defining moment for this nation in the
last few years
[Music]
it was there on August of 2017 we saw
Klansmen and white supremacists and
neo-nazis come out in the open they're
crazed faces illuminated by tortuous
veins and bulging and burying the Franks
of racism chanting the same anti-semitic
vile heard across Europe in the thirties
that's the opening same bile her to get
her in the cross Europe in the 30s
anti-semitic bile Donald Trump is a Nazi
that's the campaign that's Joe Biden's
opening salvo Donald Trump is a Nazi
therefore electa me Donald Trump is a
Nazi the same people who marched for him
marched for Hitler in the 1930s
never mind by the way that the State of
Israel named a train station at the
Wailing Wall after him never mind by the
way that Israel is about to name a town
after Donald Trump Benjamin Netanyahu
said that just the other day never mind
any of that never mind that this
president is the most a pro-israel
president in the history of this country
never mind that his daughter is a
convert to Judaism never mind
that his son-in-law who's a senior
advisor convert to Judaism himself no no
never mind that Donald Trump is a Nazi
that's the opening salvo okay
he's taken a strong punch the the the
problem with this line he actually he
makes it even more explicit so he said
he opens up on Charlottesville the dark
the torches this is what we heard in the
30s then he goes for the jugular and
explicitly ties Donald Trump to
neo-nazis and white supremacists and
that's when we heard the words the prezi
you knighted States that stunned the
world
and shock the conscience of this nation
he said there were quote some very fine
people on both sides very fine people on
both sides but those words the president
United States assigned a moral
equivalence between those spreading aid
than those are the courage to stand
against it
that is not true that did not happen
Donald Trump did not say that there were
fine people among the neo-nazis and
white nationalists and white
supremacists that did not happen
this is one of the most pernicious lies
propagated by the fake news mainstream
media over the last two years I know
that you think it happened
I know I sort of thought it happened too
because I saw the clips that were being
played and then I heard the mainstream
media people in their ties and their
suits and their serious faces so I
thought also that Donald Trump called
white nationalists and neo-nazis find
people in Charlottesville that is simply
a mass delusion propagated by the
mainstream media not only did Donald
Trump not call white nationalists and
neo-nazis
very fine people at Charlottesville he
explicitly condemned them in the same
paragraph when he was using the phrase
very fine people here is the cut that
nobody in the mainstream media is
willing to show you but you also had
people that were very fine people on
both sides you're changing history
you're changing culture and you had
people and I'm not talking about the
neo-nazis and the white nationalist
because they should be condemned
totally but you had many people in that
group other than neo-nazis and white
nationalists okay and the press has
treated them absolutely unfairly now in
the other group also you had some fine
people but you also had troublemakers
and you see them come with a with the
black outfits and with the helmets and
with the baseball bats you got a lot of
bad you had a lot of bad people in the
other group this is
objectively true it is true that there
are some race obsessed activists on the
right Donald Trump explicitly condemned
them it's also true that antifa exists
on the left and they wear their masks
and they physically assault people
happened to me happens to a lot of
speakers all around the country who are
conservative happens to a lot of
conservative activists he never ever not
once referred to neo-nazis and white
nationalists as fine people now it's a
good attack it's completely dishonest
it's a total abject lie but it's been a
good attack for two years think about
the kind of stony cynical dishonesty it
takes not just to utter that line not
just to rehash that attack but to open
your presidential campaign on a lie to
define your presidential campaign by a
race hustling cynical lie that's Joe
Biden oh nice old Joe Biden Joe Biden's
so genuine Joe Biden's do you what you
see is what you get is Joe Biden no he's
a man who has worked in politics for his
entire life he's been very successful in
politics he's been able to maintain
power for a very long time he is a jaded
cynical lying race hustling politician
that's his MO that's what he does he did
it to Mitt Romney in 2012 he's gonna let
the big banks once again write their own
rules unchain Wall Street
you're gonna put y'all back in Chains
I'm gonna put you all back into Mitt
Romney he's gonna put you all back and
change by the way most people in that
audience were black I assume you knew
that just judging by his rhetoric
they're gonna put you all back in Chains
Joe Biden did this to Mitt Romney he did
it to Mitt Romney in 2012 he did it to
Donald Trump in 2016 or 2020 now he'll
do it to you if you ever run for office
against Joe Biden he'll call you a
neo-nazi racist
slaver bigoted he'll do it because he's
totally dishonest the guy is nothing the
guy's just a big walking simper like a
giant set of teeth you know those big
giant white teeth that look about as
artificial as teeth can possibly look
that's Joe Biden that's why the attack
on him that he kisses people on the
forehead and gives them shoulder rubs
that's why that attack was never gonna
work is that's not some secret facet of
Joe Biden's political career that's the
entirety of his political career he's
just a used car salesman he just walks
around says hey I love you I love you
I'm I'm so genuine I really care about
you I will say anything you need me to
say to get your vote I'm Joe Biden I'm
really concerned I really like you
that's his whole career that's all we
expect from him now this is ironic it's
ironic that he's such a race hustler
because Joe Biden made one of the most
famously racial comments about Barack
Obama that anybody has made much more
than any Republican has made at the
presidential level he said quote while
they were running in 2008 I mean you got
the first mainstream African American
who is articulate and bright and clean
and a nice looking guy I mean that story
book man the Joe Biden called Barack
Obama the first african-american ever I
guess who is articulate and bright and
clean and a nice looking guy because I
guess according to Joe Biden most black
people are inarticulate stupid dirty and
ugly
he said the first mainstream
african-american who's articulate bright
clean and nice-looking because all those
other african-americans are inarticulate
dumb dirty and ugly according to Joe
Biden story book that story book
according to Joe Biden so has the
kickoff basically a good start it's a
good start and coming out this way with
the Charlottesville and Trump's and
Nancy even though it's completely a lie
100% made-up BS it's a good first punch
because he's attacking really hard and
the left is so wound up in their hatred
of Trump they want to see someone be a
fighter this was one of the lines about
Donald Trump in 2016 at least he's a
fighter at least he punches the downside
for Joe Biden is he's launching his
campaign on an attack ad and that
doesn't usually work when you're running
for office you you cannot just tell
people not to vote for the other person
attack ads work negative ads work but
you can't only offer that you have to
offer something positive you have to
give people a reason to vote for you
because if Joe Biden is framing this
entire campaign around Donald Trump if
the only question in this campaign is
Donald Trump it's not Donald Trump
versus Joe Biden it's just as Donald
Trump good or is Donald Trump bad Donald
Trump's gonna win because it's all about
Donald Trump it's not about you who are
you who's Joe Biden what do you do
you're that guy who dropped out of the
race in 1988 because you were a
plagiarist is that that was you you're
the guy who lost in 2008 you're a loser
is that who's Joe Biden you're the guy
who was a punchline during the Obama
administration that's you're the guy who
smells people's hair and what it who is
Joe Biden what does Joe Biden stand for
nothing because he's a walking simper
nothing cuz he's just a giant set of
dentures with legs on it that goes
around and smells girl's hair with the
little nose on top of the dentures
that's Joe Biden now it's even worse for
him because he's launching an explicitly
negative campaign when he's got 21
opponents in the Democrat Party so he's
running a
and Trump is showing you can take a
swing at Trump okay yeah okay we all
agree at Trump's terrible we hate Trump
why would we choose you over the 21
other people who were offering us a
positive message what he's hoping what
he thinks is gonna happen is because he
is the highest name recognition of
anybody in the race he thinks that he
doesn't have to offer a positive message
for himself he thinks he can ride name
recognition and slickness all the way to
the nomination that's not gonna work
it might work against people like Pete
Buddha judge or against people like
Kamala Harris who have relatively lower
name recognition it's not gonna work
against Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders
was almost the 2016 Democratic nominee
Bernie Sanders is a well known national
figure II as nearly 100% name
recognition Joe Biden can't just ride we
hate Trump we want an alternative the
only alternative we've ever heard of his
Joe Biden therefore will nominate you a
Biden we've heard of other we've heard
of Bernie Sanders forget all the other
candidates we've heard of Bernie that
that line of strategy is not gonna work
against Bernie Sanders now of course
Donald Trump comes out swinging against
Joe Biden Donald Trump is not one to
back away from a fight he answers
basically anybody who has ever said
anything negative about him so here's
his attack welcome to the race sleepy
Joe I only hope you have the
intelligence long in doubt to wage a
successful primary campaign it will be
nasty you will be dealing with people
who truly have some very sick and
demented ideas but if you make it I will
see you at the starting gate his way
with words is poetic it so he comes out
a lot of this tweet I like I like that
he's calling them all of the Democrats
sick and demented people at which they
are I like that he's questioning Joe
Biden's intelligence this is a good
attack line against Joe Biden because
Joe Biden is not very smart he he did
very poorly went to a low ranked law
school and didn't do very well in his
class he has just been a politician his
whole life intelligence is not a prereq
was
for politics actually it's a hindrance
in politics he's totally gaffe prone he
just isn't very smart so that I think
that's a pretty good line of attack
I like the idea it says I'll see you at
the starting gate it's reminding people
Joe Biden you got to get through this
primary first you're pretending you're
running against me you got to get
through 21 other Democrats the only
thing I question is sleepy Joe far be it
from me to question the nickname master
of the world Donald Trump the guy who
always seems to come up with these solid
nicknames and wire the nickname solid
crooked Hillary little Marco lyin Ted
all of the others the reason they work
is because they speak to some visual
aspect of the candidate so in the case
of Ted Cruz Ted Cruz is not a liar Ted
Cruz is an extraordinarily honest
politician but he kind of has that look
he has that look of a sort of politician
Donald Trump zoomed in on that and he
called him a liar and it worked for the
primary campaign Marco Rubio I guess
relatively he's not very tall so okay he
goes after that crooked Hillary crooked
Hillary was his best one because crooked
Hillary is crooked
it speaks to something that is really
negative that is really unlikable that
is really unattractive and it's totally
credible in her and she also looks
crooked sleepy Joe I don't know about
the point he's trying to make is that
Donald Trump has very high energy Joe
Biden has lower energy which is true
Donald Trump doesn't appear to be his
age and Joe Biden seems like an old man
it's kind of the argument that he made
about Jeb Bush he's basically saying
it's low energy Joe the the other
advantage that Sleepy has is that
arrives with creepy so creepy Joe Biden
has been a nickname for years now and
he's sort of referring to that but in an
implicit way okay that's fine
still it's a little bit weak sauce
nobody is gonna not vote for a man
because he's a little sleepy frankly
after all the tumult ooh all of the
craziness and politics of the last two
years people might want a sleepy
candidate it does often seem to be the
case that presidents
or the opposite of the presidents who
came before them so you have you have
Ronald Reagan you start out with Ronald
Reagan start out with Jimmy Carter I
mean you could take this back over for
you got Jimmy Carter he's this weak guy
timid pulling away from the world he
he's not very good on camera he's he
doesn't seem very strong then you get
Ronald Reagan you get a movie star who
says I've outlawed the Soviet Union the
bombs drop in five minutes you Ronald
Reagan the day gets into office the
hostages are released from Iran big
movement conservative guy then after
Reagan you get George HW Bush he's the
establishment wing he's the Ivy League
guy he's the deep state guy he's the
quiet reserved New England okay then
after him this this totally upright man
you get Bill Clinton just a degenerate
from the south a derelict who was using
his secretary as a human humidor in the
Oval Office then after after Bill
Clinton you get George W Bush good old
boy Christian values he's my favorite
philosopher is Jesus Christ because he
changed my heart you get that guy he ran
on restoring dignity to the Oval Office
after george w bush who in his later
years was viewed as a cowboy reckless
going in american exceptionalism
spreading democracy throughout the whole
world
you get Barack Obama Barack Obama won
that primary because he voted against
the Iraq war unlike Hillary Clinton so
you get Barack Obama he's so much better
spoken he is less prone to rhetorical
gaffes he says we're gonna pull away
from spreading democracy throughout the
world
he is liberal he apologizes for American
exceptionalism he's the opposite of a
cowboy and after Obama you get Trump so
the question is can you run against a
candidate because he's totally different
from you I don't think that's a very
good strategy now President Trump is
known to shop different tag lines
different nicknames until he comes up
with a good one I don't think sleepy Joe
is gonna be the one that we should land
on I think we've got to keep
workshopping this
he tried this with Hillary he first it
was no stamina Hillary a few other
Hillary names and he landed on crooked
which was way better I think we need to
keep workshopping sleepy Jo and keep
going after him we got a lot more to get
to but we've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube and another Kingdom
fans
Andrew clavin's book based on the
popular series is out now it is getting
rave reviews and I got to tell you the
audiobook of another kingdom is one of
the greatest performances of literature
I've ever heard whoever did that
audiobook deserves he deserves an Oscar
for it frankly go over there get the
audiobook or you can get the physical
book if you haven't picked up a copy go
to Amazon or Barnes & Noble and order
one trust me is fantastic and you will
be glad that you did we will say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube ten bucks a
month hundred dollars for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the Matt Walsh show you can test
questions in the mailbag coming right up
you get to ask questions backstage you
get another Kingdom podcast you get the
leftist tears tumblr 21 22 Democrat
candidates in the race only going to get
crazier you are going to need the tumblr
go to daily we're calm we'll be right
back
okay I was at Cal State LA the other day
you remember this so I was giving a
speech on immigration pretty basic
speech outlining facts about immigration
that the mainstream media won't tell you
outlining the case for protecting our
borders for building a border wall
outlining the negative behavior
associated with illegal immigration the
negatives for the United States the
negatives for illegal immigrants and
illegal aliens who come over themselves
a woman gets up who I assumed was a
student turns out she's actually a
member of the faculty at Cal State LA
and she proceeded to tell me that speech
is violence I could I thought she just
was making a verbal gaffe
I thought she couldn't possibly be
saying that she did here's the exchange
protester in the back what do you
support specifically use do you think
that anti-immigrant rhetoric is violent
free speech yes because you think that
speech is violence no I think that's
what that song says a conversation that
you're having is oppressive and so I am
expressing people by what I'm doing I am
I am exerting violence on people by my
speech that's what the sign says and
that's what you just said it contributes
and the protester is saying that's
exactly what I'm doing and she's saying
that's exactly what her sign means so
that means that you a faculty member at
an American public university paid for
by taxpayer dollars or conflating speech
with violence yes
speech can be violent what you are
saying contributes to systemic racism in
this country I've been to art school for
eight years
I understand liberal arts extremely well
I am an artist and I don't think you do
I'm sure you've been to art school for
eight years
you know the sciences and oh that one
disrupting speech but yes yes these
people who are yelling or disrupting my
speech and I agree it's fascism you are
interrupting me and I think that you
need to look up violence in the dick
tree or and expands your idea about
so guess what I did I looked up violence
in the dictionary I have the I have the
definition right there of violence a
noun
behavior involving physical force
intended to hurt damage or kill someone
or something I looked it up in the
dictionary if that professor that I was
speaking to has a different dictionary
I'm more than happy to read it she can
send it over here but what it looks like
is that she's completely wrong and I'm
completely right and it's very
consequential that she's wrong and I'm
right
because I'm not even a professor at a
university she is and she's saying that
speech is violence why is this so
important because the university
consists in speech we read words at the
University we have professors give
lectures we go to seminars we discuss
ideas we start with premises and speech
and then we analyze them and we come to
conclusions and we explore different
concepts the left wants to shut down
speech at universities they want to
hollow out the essence of liberal
education itself but how can they do
that the left the only way the left can
do that is with violence that's the only
way you can really shut somebody up in
the end is you need to threaten them
with violence or you need to physically
assault them now the left brings
violence to the table because they have
no arguments the right brings speeches
to the table speeches debates and
arguments so how can the left justify
using violence to shut down speech the
only way they can do it is by redefining
speech as violence because the way it
looks now when these left wingers show
up to conservative speeches and
physically assault us and threaten us
and shout us down they are the
aggressors and we are being victimized
but they can't have it look that way so
instead what they need to do is say no
no no it's not that
you're giving a speech and then I'm
responding violently it's that you are
instigating the violence you by your
very speech are committing violence on
me and I am simply defending myself
that's their argument when I punch you
in the face unprovoked I'm actually the
victim because you've
committed violence on me with your
speech I wonder how many kids these days
still hear the expression sticks and
stones can break my bones but words will
never hurt me do kids say that anymore
they said that when I was growing up you
you go up to your parents and you say
Johnny was mean to me Johnny said I'm no
good your parents say well son sticks
and stones may break my bones but words
will never hurt me
I don't think they say that anymore I
think what these professors at
universities are saying is sticks and
stones may break your bones and words
will also hurt you so if somebody says
something you don't like you should
throw a stone at them and hit them with
a stick that's what she's saying she is
hollowing out she is undermining the
essence of liberal education itself if
you live in LA your tax dollars are
paying her salary and I can't imagine
she's the only one actually she's not I
there was another professor I spoke to
it this same event who said the same
thing speeches violence
how many professors think that major
scandal this is a major scandal and
there needs to be some disciplinary
action for professors who would conflate
the two because it crumbles the entire
University itself a lot more to get to
but we don't have time so we're gonna go
to the mailbag from your fish your fish
this is probably this is from the
Twitter account my pet fish there are a
lot of fake Daily wire Twitter accounts
like Jeremy borings beard and I had a
bunch of different fake Twitter accounts
and one of them is Michael Knowles's pet
goldfish so this is from my fish I
suppose dear Michael I need spiritual
help I'm so depressed very few things
make me happy I often find myself
struggling to find reasons to continue
on to the next day I do go see a
psychologist psychiatrist weekly and I'm
on a daily antidepressant medication but
nothing seems to be helping me anymore
my family and church leaders just tell
me to get over it I don't know what else
to do or where else to turn do you know
of any religious resources that might be
able to help me improve thanks sincerely
your pet fish sorry to hear that fish
it seems to me if you're going to see a
psychologist and a psychiatrist that's
good
if the psychologist and psychiatrist are
not helping you should get a new
psychologist and psychiatrist I know
multiple people who have been helped by
their psychologists I know many more
people who have not been and I think
it's because very often today
psychologists are really psychiatrists
are just glorified drug dealers who
don't ever treat the actual problems
they're just giving you a prescription
for some antidepressant drugs and by the
way you're not alone
the entire country is extremely
depressed one in six Americans is on
antidepressant drugs one in 20 American
teenagers between 12 and 17 or on
antidepressant drugs when people get on
these drugs they remain on them
for a very long period of time diagnosis
of anxiety depression stress are way way
up teen suicide this way way up 70% this
is a major epidemic that cannot simply
be explained by psychiatry they cannot
simply be explained as a as a medical
condition there seems to be a
philosophical problem here as well so
what I would recommend is if the
psychologist or psychiatrist you're
seeing is good stick with them if not go
get a new one you should make sure to be
in in consultation with doctors who can
treat the medical side of it whatever it
is there is also a philosophical and a
spiritual issue here one issue I think
that is leading to this epidemic is that
we expect to be happy all the time
we love pleasure we expect gratification
we look on Instagram and everybody's
eating $200 meals every night and
everybody is at some beach in the
Caribbean every day because we are
seeing all around us only the highlight
reel of people's lives and especially if
you find yourself as someone who is on
the internet most of the time rather
than in the real world you will get a
completely warped view of what the real
world is really like now another side of
this is our society has lost the sense
of suffering we think suffering is evil
we think suffering is bad suffering is
not evil or bad at all suffering is
morally neutral
the only moral question is our reaction
to suffering st. Paul writes about this
Saint Paul says I rejoice in my
suffering for I am making up in my flesh
that for you that which is lacking in
the suffering of Christ in the cross of
Christ that suffering has a sanctifying
quality this is the old expression that
you hear old Catholics sometimes say
they say kiss it up to God
oh you're hurting kiss it up to God
there's real wisdom in this the great
saints of history all suffered immensely
suffering is a fact of existence you can
react to suffering with self-pity or
with blandness or with apathy or with
lethargy or you can accept suffering as
a cross to bear take up your cross just
that mental switch just that switch and
perception I I have found has gotten me
through difficult periods of time we
don't allow for grief we don't allow for
those feelings the other thing then is
in this society that we're in I think we
very often convince ourselves nothing
really matters we're all just sort of
atoms floating around bags of chemicals
life is a tale told by an idiot full of
sound and fury signifying nothing oh
we're all gonna just turn to worm food
someday it doesn't really matter there's
no moral law it doesn't matter if I get
out of bed in the morning it does God
exists God created you you have a
purpose that there will be a final
accounting you will be held to account
for what you did for the life that you
were given that you did not create that
you do not exactly deserve that was
given to you freely as a gift this is
why sloth is a sin we think about sins
we focus on sexual sins or a sense of
wrath and anger sloth is a sin - you
only have a certain number of minutes in
this world you have to make sure you use
them in a way that is respectful and
grateful for the gift that you've been
given this society
we're in right now is so radically
skeptical we are taught that you have to
doubt everything we should just doubt
every single thing we can't be certain
of anything that's the exact opposite
way to look at the world coordinate
Newman wrote about this John Henry
Newman one of the great thinkers in all
of history wrote about this in the idea
of the University about how our
education system is exactly backwards we
have this idea that action follows from
belief that's not true belief follows
from action we are active creatures we
live in time and space we do things
we're on the move we're not just brains
floating in the air where there's no
stakes there's no urgency we are actors
in this great comedy of the world and
when you lose that sense of purpose it's
easy to fall into a sort of despair what
is despair it means the absence of hope
what what is your hope what are we
hopeful for in this culture we're
hopeful for nothing we're optimistic we
pretend to be hopeful we say oh well you
know let's be happy and I'm happy and
let's self-love and let's affirm
ourselves and let's just be happy it's
who are you trying to convince you can't
be happy you can't be happy because you
want to be happy happiness is a fleeting
feeling joy is real joy is not always
happy joy comes from Hope which is the
opposite of despair and what does hope
it's a theological virtue faith hope and
charity faith hope and love if you find
that you're pitying yourself it's not
that you should think less of yourself
you should think of yourself less go do
something outside of yourself especially
in the real world not on the internet
the internet is a bad place for this
sort of despair and I have no doubt that
the rise of the Internet the rise of
social media are in part to blame for
this widespread epidemic of despair
throughout the country we could go on
about this for a long time but I hope
that begins to help young fish from
Veronica
hey Mikey poo how many electoral votes
would California lose if the number were
based on legal citizens versus total
population shouldn't the electoral votes
reflect in
number of voters anyway am I totally
wrong about how this works thanks this
is a great point this is why there's now
a battle over the u.s. census so at
various points we've asked on the census
whether you're a citizen or not
Democrats don't like this currently that
question is not on the census
Republicans want to put it back on the
Trump administration wants to put it
back on the left is is challenging this
it went up to the Supreme Court and in
oral arguments the courts conservatives
seem to suggest that they would allow
the question to go back on the census it
looks like it'll be a 5-4 decision now
the argument from the left is that the
primary purpose of the census is to
count the number of people not the
number of citizens so we shouldn't ask
that question now that's true but we ask
plenty of other questions on the census
we ask questions about sex we ask
questions about race and ethnicity we
ask you all sorts of questions
so if we take out the citizenship
question certainly we should take out
all those other questions if we don't
take out all these other questions I
think it's very clear that while the
primary purpose might be to count the
number of people there are many other
purposes as well what this comes down to
is a battle over immigration it comes
back to immigration again because
illegal immigrants are already giving an
unfair advantage to Democrats why is
that because they tend to be in blue
places they artificially inflate the
population in those places and then as
the seats are allocated in Congress
Democrats get greater representation now
that's very unfair that's a bug of our
Constitution it's a bug of our
immigration system I imagine that when
the framers were writing our
Constitution they did not expect that
there would be tens of millions of
illegal aliens living in the country
radically changing our representation as
a matter of fact in the Constitution
they leave Native Americans out of those
counts because they're a separate nation
they are foreign nationals well that's
certainly the case for the foreign
nationals who enter our country
illegally and reside here it does give
an unfair advantage to Democrats that's
why the census battle is going to be so
important hopefully the Supreme Court
stays strong hey Michael I'm starting a
summer internship in a
lab at the end of this month the current
lab intern has been training me to do
the job all month and I've developed a
huge crush on her the only issue is that
she's moving back home post graduation
well I've still got another year of
school should I still go for it and tell
her I like her
Thanks anonymous just in case she
listens to your show all the cute girls
listen to my show so that's a good that
you used anonymous absolutely of course
do turn off this program and go do it
right now why not she's cute
you like her you've got some things in
common you've got to kiss the girl to go
do it what are you talking you're a
young guy go have fun from Alec hey
Michael what is the origin of the idea
of purgatory and is it biblically based
love the show yes very good question
most people don't understand purgatory
which makes it difficult to understand
literature lots of obviously Dante or
Shakespeare makes it very understand
difficult to understand so many of these
references in our culture purgatory is
biblical like the Trinity it's not
explicitly named in the Bible the
Trinity is not explicitly named in the
Bible but the Trinity is very biblical
we can easily deduce the Trinity and we
can easily deduce purgatory purgatory is
purification to achieve the holiness
necessary to enter the joy of heaven so
it's a purification it's very different
from Hell which is punishment for the
Damned purgatory is a sanctification a
purification to achieve the perfection
that will get you into heaven and the
holiness what is the biblical basis for
this Christ in Matthew refers to the
sinner who will quote not be forgiven
either in this age or in the age to come
so what we can deduce from this is that
it is logically possible to be forgiven
in this age or in the age to come we
know we can be forgiven in this age but
what does it look like to be forgiven in
the age to come to be forgiven in the
age to come implies that there isn't
there is something other than eternal
torment that also
involves a purification or a need for
forgiveness or an imperfection st. Paul
does this as well st. Paul discusses
what happens when a righteous man is
judged and the righteous man fails the
trial fails the test he says in the
first letter of the Corinthians he will
suffer loss though he himself will be
saved but only as through fire so this
is the explicit imagery of the fire of
purgatory even if he's a righteous man
but his works fail the test he will
suffer loss he will be saved he will
only be saved as though through fire we
see this in Maccabees there are prayers
for the dead in Maccabees meaning that
there is some hope for the dead who are
not yet in paradise not yet in
perfection for those people who wanted
to get rid of purgatory who wanted to
deny the existence of purgatory in the
16th century they just got rid of the
book of Maccabees from the Bible just
because just because Maccabees was so
clear about this that they had to erase
it in order to help them erase purgatory
we also see in Revelation we know that
nothing unclean will enter the presence
of God in heaven we know in Hebrews that
it is appointed for men to die once and
that after that death comes the judgment
though there is another judgment at the
end of time when Christ returns that is
the general judgment and we hear Christ
say in Luke I tell you you will never
get out till you have paid the very last
copper but there is some purification
there is some period between a judgment
between death and getting out how do you
get out if there's an unbridgeable gulf
between heaven and hell this is
purgatory and and this goes back very
far we know that Monica st. Monica the
mother of st. Augusta the author of the
City of God asked her son in the fourth
century to remember her soul in the
masses why would she ask her son to
remember her soul her son the Bishop of
Hippo or bishop one was he I guess
benefit yeah my gosh I'm like getting
totally confused
she asks her son to remember her soul
because she
doubts that her soul will be in heaven
that there's some something where her
soul might very well be so anyway
there's there a lot of Atta stations of
purgatory in the Bible in Scripture in
the church tradition and I think it
would be much better if people would be
open to these questions because when one
takes a purely narrow rigid literal view
of pieces of Scripture you lose so much
of the faith you lose the Trinity itself
but when you are open to what is clearly
there though not always spelled out in
exactly the words you want it to be
spelled out in you you open yourself up
to the truth and the magnitude of the
faith all right that's all we have time
for we've got to well we've got a lot
more to get to but unfortunately we just
don't have time so I will see you on
Monday in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael an old show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show Joe Biden jumps into
the race and we break it all down that's
today on the bench Shapiro show